educate and when I say they I'm talking
about either our higher self our soul
our guides our deceased loved ones they
try to communicate and guide us all the
time but we have to be open to it that's
one reality then here in the physical I
feel that we have almost become like two
worlds there is the world that is living
in fear and then there is the world that
can see through the fear could you call
that heaven and hell yes you you pretty
much could so Heaven and Hell exists
right here on Earth it's not in the
afterlife it's right here on Earth the
afterlife is I just call it pure love
pure Consciousness but heaven and hell
is right here so Heaven is seeing
through the fear hell is living in the
fear the people that live in the fear
they live in the fear because there is a
fear of things like a fear of scarcity
they live in a world of scarcity a world
of competition there isn't enough to go
around so I have to get ahead of
everybody else